[Musique]
bonjour bonjour patrick bredas candidats
aux élections municipales pour le second
tour au marigot où donc le taux de
participation que nous avons que nous
trouvons un peu partout concernant cette
commune pour le premier tour a été de
55,57 % à l'issue de ce premier tour
c'est le maire sortant joseph peraste
qui est arrivé en tête avec 848 vois ce
qui se sont portés sur son nom soit 49
points 47% des suffrages
ange lavenaire se plaçant en deuxième
position s'ils ont pu dire avec 25
points 32% des suffrages exprimés et
puis vous patrick bredas vous êtes en en
troisième position avec 19 points 66 %
de suffrages exprimés sur votre voix
donc soit 337 voix il y avait un
quatrième candidat au premier tour
monsieur daniel gros désir mais qui n'a
recueilli que près de 6% des suffrages
et donc qui n'est pas en lice pour le
pour le second tour alors patrick bredas
vous êtes la tête de la liste l'alliance
nouvelle
comment percevez-vous ses résultats du
premier tour qui vous placent donc
troisièmes de la triangulaire mais loin
quand même du score enregistré par par
le maire sortant
alors tout d'abord je tiens à vous
remercie pour votre invitation et puis
bien entendu vous remercier les 337
margotin qu'ils ont et marigot tine qui
ont porté leurs suffrages sur notre
liste l'alliance nouvelle mais pour
l'analyse que je fais de ces élections
de celle des résultats de ces élections
du 15 mars c'est que tout simplement les
mains ligotées ont signifié au même en
place qu'il n'était pas encore d'accord
pour valider son projet qui n'a revient
revient de particuliers ni rien qui
fasse appel au bon sens marie gaudin et
deuxièmement ils ont dit à l'ancien
maire monsieur l'avenir que ce qu'il
pensait être une injustice de 83 à voir
en 2014 a été corrigé et que le peuple
tient à tourner la page par contre pour
nous et nous ont donné un élément de
plus pour continuer
rappelez-vous qu'en 2014 nous ne faisons
que
17% des voix aujourd'hui et nous confie
2% de plus près de 20 % d'accord des
voix dont ça nous met dans une position
qui nous dit après tout pourquoi pas et
ce deuxième tout nous sommes prêts à
l'affronter avec nos arguments avec une
s'arroger ça vous encourage donc mais
pour quoi faire quoi n'avoir pas tenté
une union avec ange lavenaire patrick
bredas si l'objectif est bien de déloger
joseph peraste du fauteuil de maire de
marigot alors c'est là que nous tirons
notre analyse effectivement nous allons
combattre le projet de monsieur joseph
piras le déloger avec l'accord de la
population mais pas faire alliance à
n'importe quel prix écoutez je le dis
ouvertement en toute sincérité
nous avons eu une rencontre avec
monsieur l'avenir mais ça n'a pas tourné
très très content parce que monsieur
l'avenir pour lui et a pas de personne
capable de déloger monsieur perez à la
tête de la municipalité et nous lui
avons fait comprendre que les résultats
qu'il enregistrait dans les années 2000
aujourd'hui il veut grèce de près de 600
voix et nous on a une marge de
progression groupe où l'avenir et qu'il
était peut-être venu le moment de donner
au gouvernement voulait donc il ne
couvrira pas bien goûter il n'a pas
voulu nous avons compris très rapidement
que c'était pas le projet mais c'était
simplement une question de vengeance
personnelle et vous comprendrez bien que
l'équipe que j'anime n'a pas ce type
d'engagement avec la population nous
voulons aller avec un projet qu une
certitude
un pur j'ai fait pour la population mais
parce que bon c'est que la politique
évidemment c'est pas que de
l'arithmétique pas du tout une purée
précise mais si on additionne les voix
que vous avez recueilli plus la petite
marge qui qui qui reste puisque il ya eu
55 % de participation mais elle n'est
pas si énorme que ça donc peut-être qu'à
vous deux vous auriez pu faire basculer
effectivement le résultat je vous dit
que ça n'est jamais le marigot temps
s'ils ont envie de faire le choix ils
ont tout le champ du récit c'est parce
que dites-vous aux citoyennes et
citoyens de marigot pour les convaincre
de vous permettre de renverser un
résultat qui paraît a priori quand même
tout de même un peu difficile ja
durement et gauthey vous avez entre vos
mains
l'outil qu'il faut avez votre bulletin
de vote
avez vu ma détermination vous connaissez
mes engagements sous la ville de marigot
pendant cette période de crise sanitaire
vous avez bien vu ce que j'ai entrepris
et je profite de votre antenne pour dire
que nous n'avons pas hésité pendant que
certains l'occurrence monsieur l'avenir
et monsieur perez était bien gentiment
lové à sept maris moi j'ai pris mon
bâton de pèlerin
j'ai distribué près de 3000 masques à la
population de marigot quand on va garder
dans les autres communes où ils sont
obligés d'attendre sous les et comité
communauté d'agglo pour avoir 300 ou 400
masse dans les communes de même strate
que le mari je veux vous allez bien vous
procurer aux 3000 masques oui par mon
réseau et puis par ma détermination
envers ce peuple un goûter parce qu'il y
avait ce besoin mais maintenant je n'ai
pas fait pour acheter des voix pas du
tout simplement
c'est dans ma proximité avec le peuple
en égouttant que joly fait j'ai fait
d'autres actions aussi à savoir la
distribution de paniers aux personnes
les plus méritantes et surtout les
personnes âgées qui sont les plus
fragilisés mais je les fais avec mon
coeur avec ce désir de servir
et voilà donc au marigot temps de se
réveiller d'avancé sur sur citoyens et
jadis hutus au 1400 personnes qui se
sont pas déplacés ce que je peux
comprendre avec la crise sanitaire
mais maintenant en entendant seule cette
voie de se réveiller et de participer à
ce sursaut et je suis persuadé qu'il ya
une volonté divine souls margot qui voit
que les choses vont bouger
dernière précision monsieur gros désir
le quatrième candidat du premier tour
s'est il prononcé alors voulu elle vous
l'avait sollicité pour qu'il vous
souvienne c'est une raison de plus qui
nous a pas permis d'avoir l'alliance
avec monsieur l'avenir parce que
monsieur gaudin qu'il a combattu avec
monsieur p as en 2014 et qui lui aussi
il faut déjà à la population a combattu
monsieur ps avec lequel il a partagé
cette victoire contre monsieur l'avenir
il n'était pas question de l'un pour
nous d'aller nous a lancé avec des
personnes qui n'ont qu'un seul objectif
la haine la vengeance et la rancune
merci non c'est le projet pour le
marigot
avec cette belle équipe dont j'ai
l'immense plaisir de manager merci
patrick bredas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions avec les yeux